un sourire contre moment d'attention
un geste peut-être en faveur des
familles en difficulté à l'entrée de cet
hypermarché des bénévoles de la croix
rouge ne ménagent pas leurs efforts
d'accord vous remercie d'abord dans mes
possibilités je donne savez ce que c'est
devoir investir pour la rentrée scolaire
ah oui oui moi je suis passé par là
aussi un jeu c'est qu'est ce que c'est
et la liste n'est pas courte
aujourd'hui ils sont une quarantaine à
uvrer pour recueillir cahiers et crayons
trousses et cartables ou petit matériel
de dessin et de géométrie l'opération
visiblement est populaire auprès du
public
selon les moyens l'on donne un peu ou
beaucoup mais avec le même esprit
j'ai donné une boîte de crayons de
couleur parce que je suis conscient
qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont
en difficulté moi même aussi j'étais en
difficulté
et puis voilà quoi il faut partager au
partage et on peut en partage
c'est important d'apprendre ça aux
enfants pour pour que plus tard et
puissent aussi apprendre à leurs enfants
à partager à donner aux gens qui n'ont
pas les moyens même si on a un petit peu
après une journée de collecte dans une
dizaine de grandes surfaces la croix
rouge parvient en général remplir une
centaine de cartons comme celui ci mais
l'on sent tout de même que les temps
sont durs
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que il ya
autant de personnes qui donnent même je
pense que d'une année sur l'autre on est
de plus en plus nombreux le problème
c'est que les gens donnent beaucoup
moins je pense que la situation
technique hier personnelle des gens fait
que font que finalement ils ne peuvent
pas donner autant qu'il souhaiterait
donner mais ils sont ils viennent vers
nous en tout cas ils sont dans la
générosité et nous donne avec le petit
mot vaille le petit mot de gentillesse
qui accompagne le don c'est ça nous
encourage en fait c'est formidable
lundi les associations de l'île qui
offre directement auprès des familles
viendront chercher les dons à la
croix-rouge
le siège de fort de france se trouve rue
du capitaine manuel aux terres sainville
il accueillera tous les matins de la
semaine les généreux donateurs qui
auraient manqué la collecte en jambes
[Musique]